no the mattress was incredible yeah the
pillow was incredible only one pillow
what person sees it one pillow no I'm a
two pillow guy if you sleep on one
pillow go to prison yeah you'll be fine
in prison I don't understand one pillow
and I don't understand when you check
into like like I don't know what like a
like a Residence Inn or like an Embassy
Suites or those pillows [__] horrible
[__] pillows I hate those
[__] and I hate the people who
decided that they should have those
[__] pillows [__] [__] but
like if I really want my best night's
sleep it's five pillows if I if I have
less than three I have to make some type
of accommodation for myself so if wait a
minute you can't sleep with two pillows
I cannot I won't fall asleep I go one
between the legs one between the arms
one under the head one above the head
like a sandwich until you can't breathe
blocks out all the sound and light I
have a CPAP machine so I still get
pumped off no I got one behind my back
and I tuck it in so it has back support
I mean what do you have a living nurse I
mean how are you doing this one two
three four five pillows it's terrible
that I arrived here because there's no
going back but now I'm getting older I'm
getting into my set ways and I have a
special way that I sleep